bonjour pour votre côté pour d'inquiéter
assoyez-vous là les mecs en ce temps là
jésus jésus a attaqué et assiégé
territoire non ça va en ce temps là
jésus il dit à ses disciples
les petits mecs si qu'on allait faire
une virée sur le lac de tibériade
qu'edith bongo qui fait saint-pierre
vendeuse qui est des jeunes rue des
bikers toi tu vas tu as a souhaité dès
qu'ils aient fait jésus parce que je
veux dire entretient aussi sa queue ils
enfourchent leur moto
ice-t en direction le lac tibériade
or là j'ai les yeux qui était pas chef
de bande pour rien du tout il fait lé
mexique on allait faire du ski nautique
qui fait du ski nautique
ouais ok ils disent tous sauf saint jean
baptiste jean baptiste qu'avait des
rhumatismes
oui dans les genoux à force de rester
dans la flotte ont vite fait idée car
direction la baraque du ski nautique
tranquille manque de pot fermé cause de
sa batte a dit donc c'est un programme
qui fait saint pierre parce qu' on va
quand même pas rentrer pour voir à la
télé gates dans sa bannette avouent
qu'ils font
on laisse tomber je fais quoi boire les
potes qui fait santana qui avait touché
jamais touché le jazz c'est dans l'ordre
car la leaf jésus vise un peu l'artiste
et puis là jésus y pensons et non
excusées way i coups reçus lors il fonce
vers la flotte était pas l eia qui fait
eau les met un peu vexant les skis sans
les skis et c'est ainsi mes bien chers
frères k o chez eux
il marcha sur les os